[Music]
a fundamental question in evolutionary
biology is the evolution of ornament
especially sexual ornament and one way
to look at that how that evolves is to
ask why are certain traits preferred the
Peacocks tail or the song of a wood
thrush in the Origin of Species Charles
Darwin proposed that organisms evolved
by natural selection to become more and
more adapted to their environment in
proposing this mechanism Darwin
articulated the concept of fitness which
was an aspect of the individual that
allowed it to further its own survival
or fecundity it was like physical
fitness it was something the individual
could do in order to further its
survival however later during the early
20th century with the development of
modern population genetics the idea of
fitness the concept of fitness was
redefined in an abstract mathematical
way to mean one's relative contribution
of one's genes to subsequent populations
in this case Fitness incorporated both a
survival and fecundity and a
differential reproductive success or
natural selection and sexual selection
this is okay except that the new revised
concept of Fitness kept its romantic
association with the idea of adaptation
by natural selection even though it
applied to both survival and mate choice
which which Darwin saw as essentially an
aesthetic process right so what that
means is that in the early 20th century
evolutionary biology and selection
became synonymous with natural selection
right this had a number of problems
which for example it built right into
the machinery of evolutionary biology
the idea that mate choice is always
adaptive or is or should be about
adaptation 100% of evolutionary
biologists from about 1890 to 90
thirty-eight were either ardent you
Genesis or happy fellow-travellers . and
that unfortunate past is really part of
our history as a discipline and I think
evolutionary biology has a special
responsibility to scrutinize the
intellectual developments during that
period and the way in which those those
concepts influence the way we think
about evolution today animals have an
opportunity for sensory perception
cognitive evaluation and choice and
based on their choices certain kinds of
ornament will evolve according to the
beauty happens theory beauty evolves
merely because its preferred and what
that means is that in in a population
mate choice will create some norm some
standard that is preferred within the
population but also that standard is
unstable over time it can change now
this theory beauty happens goes back to
Charles Darwin who proposed after the
Origin of Species
an alternative or new theory for the
evolution of ornament through mate
choice or sexual selection when Darwin
proposed that mate choice was a force in
evolution back in the Victorian era the
idea was a big loser among his
colleagues they were very skeptical that
animals could be even capable of choice
let alone the kind of aesthetic
judgments that that Darwin proposed or
under the wall a.cian view all beauty is
merely another kind of practical utility
that beauty like the Peacocks tail is
preferred because it indicates something
about that individual either that he has
good genes or a good diet or no sexually
transmitted diseases all sorts of things
that mates need to know the challenge of
course is to try to figure out what's
actually happening in nature modern
evolutionary biologists are quite
comfortable with the idea that animals
are making choices if they still are by
and large confident
that the kinds of choices that animals
make will always be controlled by or
determined by natural selection that is
that mate choice will ultimately lead to
the evolution of adaptive or honest
ornaments this flattening simplification
of the Darwinian worldview directly
contributed to the eugenic history of
evolutionary biology that is during the
late 19th and early 20th century a 100%
of evolutionary biologists believed that
human diversity had evolved as a result
of adaptation to to diversity of
environments and this meant that human
populations ethnic groups and races were
actually adapted to different
environments in a hierarchy of quality
right this of course was this eugenic
theory actually failed to be supported
and it has been scientifically rejected
and yet aspects of the logic of eugenics
were built into the early or fundamental
concepts of modern evolutionary biology
through the concept of fitness so how do
we proceed forward I think the best way
is to define natural selection and
sexual selection as distinct mechanisms
sometimes interacting this is a return
to the Darwinian concept of the
Darwinian structure of evolutionary
biology and I think it's one that
actually will inoculate evolutionary
biology from its eugenic roots by
essentially uncoupling made choice from
the definition of adaptation I think of
this like a spinning top may choice
creates the forces that allows the top
to spin and stand on its own in one
place but over time with small
disruptions the top can skitter from one
place or one direction or another so
what that means is as species form they
tend to evolve new and different
varieties of beauty each more complex
than the last like a spinning top if you
spin it a 10,000 times each time it'll
arrive at a different place and that's
one way in which I think the beauty
happens theory looks a lot like nature
itself where different species all have
different ideas about what's beautiful
[Music]